HERE AT THIS MEETING WE WANT TO
GO AHEAD AND BEGIN -- THE
COMMITTEE IS A SUB COMMITTEE --
NOTICING THAT WE HAVE THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM I ALSO LIKE
TO ANNOUNCE IN ADVANCE ARE THE
MISTER GIBSON WILL BE
SUBSTITUTING FOR MR GARCIA.
AND MISS CERVANTES WILL BE
ABSENT FROM TODAY'S MEETING
HEARING.
AND NOW WILL BE A CALLING THE
AUTHORS
.
JUST REMINDING EVERYBODY OF A
COUPLE HOUSEKEEPING RULES ARE WE
HAVE SPECIAL ORDER BUSINESS AND
A. B. ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT MULLIN
WOULD BE HEARD FIRST.
ARE.
ALSO ANOTHER -- POINT OVER WITH
UNANIMOUS CONSENT WERE PUTTING
ON TWO BILLS ON CONSENT THAT
ENJOYS SUPPORT SUPPORT -- THAT
WOULD BE A. B. NINE FIFTY SIX I
DEEP AND AB FOURTEEN OH NINE
CHAO.
WHEN THE TIME COMES WILL NEED A
MOTION?
AND ALSO FOR THE PRESENTATIONS
WILL BE ALONG ONLY THREE
WITNESSES WITH.
I TWO MINUTES EACH.
I USE IT WISELY.
AND THERE'S NO NEED TO FEEL YOU
NEED TO USE A MALL.
TO WE WILL BE ABLE.
TO TELL [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
GEN
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
UHHUH [inaudible]
HELLO.
UNDER THE ONE CONCERN.
PROVIDED THE THINGS ON THE
PROGRAM
.
UP MISTER MULLIN WE'RE STARTING
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE OF THAT BE
OKAY WITH YOU.
AND WE DID LAID OUT SOME GROUND
RULES -- THREE WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH.
I NEED SIDE.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS.
PRESENTING A. B..
ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT ON TEXT TO
NINE ONE ONE AB ELEVEN SIXTY
EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
IMPLEMENT A TEXT THE NINE ONE
ONE SERVICE. TO ALL COUNTIES BY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS BILL
WOULD BENEFIT THE DEAF AND HARD
OF HEARING COMMUNITY.
BY PROVIDING EQUAL ACCESS TO
EMERGENCY SERVICES WHEN THEY
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO T. T. Y. OR
VIDEO RELAY SERVICES.
IN CALIFORNIA TT WHY IS IT VIDEO
RELAY SERVICES ARE THE WAYS OF
COMMUNICATING WITH EMERGENCY
DISPATCHERS.
WHEN IN NEED OF HELP FOR THE
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
COMMUNITY?
VIDEO RELAY SERVICES ARE
ACCESSIBLE THROUGH A THIRD PARTY
IT ALLOWS THE INTERPRETER TO SEE
THE CALLER.
BUT THE ACCESS TO NINE ONE ONE
IS SOMETIMES DELAYED DUE TO
TRANSLATION VERSUS A DIRECT TEXT
MESSAGE.
AS NEW TECHNOLOGY KEEPS
ADVANCING T. T. Y. AND VIDEO
RELAY SERVICES ARE NOT THE MOST
ACCESSIBLE FORM OF COMMUNICATION
WITHIN THE DEAF OR HARD OF
HEARING COMMUNITY.
JUST LIKE PEOPLE IN GENERAL THEY
ARE RELYING ON INSTANT MESSAGING
TEXT MESSAGING EMAIL OR VIDEO
COMMUNICATION THROUGH SMART
PHONES OR COMPUTERS.
MY HOME COUNTY OF SAN MATTEO AND
SACRAMENTO ARE AMONG THE
COUNTIES OUT OF IMPLEMENTED TAX
TO NINE ONE ONE TECHNOLOGY.
ALLOWING ITS CITIZENS TO REACH
AN EMERGENCY DISPATCH WHEN IT'S
UNSAFE FOR ON FEASIBLE TO CALL.
THIS TECHNOLOGY WOULD ALSO BE
HELPFUL TO THOSE WHO FIND
THEMSELVES IN SITUATIONS WHERE
IT MIGHT BE TOO DANGEROUS TO
DIAL.
911- SCENARIOS COULD INCLUDE
DOMESTIC ABUSE INCIDENTS.
ACCIDENTS THAT CAUSE IN ABILITY
TO SPEAK.
OR EVEN ACTIVE SHOOTER
SITUATIONS.
WITH ME TODAY IS SHERRY FARIDA.
CEO OF NOR CAL SERVICES FOR DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL [inaudible]
YEAH OKAY.
YEAH.
AND I AM THERE HE OF NOR CAL
CENTER ON DEAFNESS.
AND IT'S GOOD TO SEE ALL OF YOU
HERE TODAY.
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT'S NEEDED.
AND REALLY I WANT TO START WITH
A PERSONAL STORY TO EMPHASIZE
THIS MY SON FELL AND HURT
HIMSELF WHEN HE WAS JUMPING ON
THE BED.
AND ENDED UP HITTING HIS HEAD ON
THE WINDOW SILL.
HE WAS BLEEDING PROFUSELY AND I
WAS TRYING TO GRAB A TOWEL AND
HOLD IT TO HIS BLEEDING HEAD
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME USE A TTY
DEVICE TO CALL.
911- AND SO THERE WAS THREE
TIMES BAY HUNG UP ON ME.
AND I FINALLY HAD TO GIVE UP
GRAB MY SON AND RUSHED HIM OFF
TO THE HOSPITAL ON MY OWN.
AND IT WAS SIX HOURS LATER WHEN
WE WERE BACK AT HOME THEN L. A.
P. D. SHOWED UP -- WITH A
BUSINESS CARD AND LEFT IT AT OUR
DOOR.
AND SAID THAT THEY HAD STOPPED
BY DUE TO MY CALL SO OF COURSE I
FILED A COMPLAINT WITH THE US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND AT THAT TIME.
I'M THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE THERE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL Y. AS JANET RENO.
SO.
SHE TOOK MY CASE.
AN ORDERED THAT -- WE HAD TO HAD
MAJOR CITIES IN THE UNITED
STATES COMPLIANCE WITH NINE ONE
ONE RULES.
SO AS YOU CAN SEE THE DEAF
COMMUNITY HAS REALLY NOT ANY
CONFIDENCE.
IN WHAT IS BEING ABLE TO BE
ACCESSIBLE TO THEM.
AND THIS IS WHY WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE ACCESSIBLE SERVICES --
THROUGH THE FCC JUST LIKE ANYONE
ELSE [inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
I'VE BEEN ADVISED ME TO PAUSE
FOR JUST ONE SECOND [inaudible]
BUT THERE
.
PLEASE CONTINUE IN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SURE [inaudible]
WE NEED.
SO WITH BIG.
THE EMERGENCY ACCESS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE IN TWENTY TWELVE
RECOMMENDED THAT WE HAVE TEXT TO
NINE ONE ONE AND THAT NEEDED TO
BE I'M ON HOLD AND TELL WEEK
COULD HAVE HAPPENED OTHER
MEETING ABOUT.
NINE ONE ONE BUT I DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE WISDOM WE NEED
DIRECT SERVICES.
TO NINE ONE ONE SO EVER SINCE
TWENTY TWELVE WE HAVE BEEN
WAITING AND WAITING AND WE'VE
WAITED LONG ENOUGH IT'S TIME NOW
THE TECHNOLOGY IS THERE.
THE MEANS ARE THERE AND SO I
BELIEVE THAT IT IS TIME NOW IT
THERE'S ALREADY A FEW COUNTIES
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT ALREADY HAVE TEXT TO NINE
ONE ONE SO THERE'S NO EXCUSE.
THAT THE ENTIRE STATE DOESN'T
DEMAND THAT WE HAVE IT
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND SO WE NEED TO HAVE IT
THROUGH ALL THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES -- IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT
IN MEANS A LOT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WITNESSES
[inaudible]
YEAH.
SEE NO MAN AND DIGITAL SUPPORT
WITNESSES [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL.
FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS FRANCIS
DETERMINE AND I'M ADVOCATE
SERVICES FOR TO KERA AND DEATH
COUNSELLING AND REFERRAL AGENCY.
AND I HAVE A PERSONAL STORY AS
WELL AS A DEAF PERSON -- I WAS
IN AN ABUSIVE MARRIAGE AND MY EX
HUSBAND.
OF PREVENTING ME FROM LEAVING
THE HOUSE.
HE DISABLED THE CAR THERE WAS NO
ONE AROUND ME I WAS IN THE
MIDDLE OF A VIOLENT SITUATION
HOW WAS I ABLE TO GET OUT I
COULDN'T CALL FOR HELP.
AND NOBODY WAS THERE IF I HAD A
PHONE TO TEXT TO NINE ONE ONE I
WOULD HAVE IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO
HELP AND I WOULD BE ABLE TO GET
OUT OF THAT IMMEDIATE THAT
DANGEROUS VERY DANGEROUS
SITUATION.
AND I'M THINKING OF OTHER PEOPLE
THAT ARE INVOLVED IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AS A MOTHER -- I MY
DAUGHTER IT WAS THREE AND IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT SHE HAD --
SHE WASN'T ABLE TO PLEASE BREED
SHE WAS CRYING AND I HAD TO GO
THROUGH THE VIDEO RELAY SERVICE
CALL 911- BUT BECAUSE I WAS
USING MY LAPTOP.
I WAS COMPLETELY DISCONNECTED
AND SO -- I HAD TO CALL UBER AND
I HAD TO GO THE HOSPITAL ON MY
OWN AND I COULD HAVE EASILY BEEN
PRESENT PREVENTED HAD I HAD NINE
ONE ONE ACCESS.
SO THIS BILL IF PASSED WOULD
CERTAINLY HELP A LOT OF DEAF
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY AT ALL
AROUND CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
JUST WANT TO REMIND EVERYBODY
THAT WE'RE ALLOWING THREE PEOPLE
AT TWO MINUTES SO ONE MORE
PERSON GETS.
A TWO MINUTE AFTER THAT IT'S
ONLY NAME ORGANIZATION A
SUPPORTER OPPOSE PERIOD THANK
YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
MY NAME IS RACHEL AND I HAD A
SIMILAR STERIC STORY AS AS
SHERRY AND ALSO -- THE PREVIOUS
AS A THIRD.
PARTY -- I HAVE TO HAVE GOOD
QUALITY INTERNET IF YOU'RE OUT
IN THE COUNTRY AND YOU CAN'T
CALL 911- BECAUSE THERE'S NOT
INTERNET YOU'RE NOT ACCESSIBLE
TO THE EMERGENCY SERVICES.
SO AGAIN NOT EVERYONE HAS
INTERNET ACCESS SO IT.
TEXT TO NINE ONE ONE IS IS
CERTAINLY AN IMPORTANT FOR
EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY LIVE AND THEN IT WOULD
CERTAINLY SAVE A LOT OF LIVES
AND GET US OUT OF A HORRIBLE
EXPERIENCES SO THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO ME TODAY.
REMIND EVERYBODY FROM HERE ON
JUST NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION THANK YOU.
HELLO MY MY NAME IS AN AMBER
TANSLEY I WORK FOR TO CORPS.
DE CARA AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANTHONY JOHNSON I
WORK FOR TO KERA AND I ALSO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND MY NAME IS JEFF TOWARD A KIA
A PUBLIC ADVOCATE [inaudible]
KERA OWL.
ACTUALLY PHYSICAL AXES SOME
SACRAMENTO IN TAX -- TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANKING SEEING NO ADDITIONAL US
SUPPORT WITNESSES ANY MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
FAMOUS FIVE YOU WILL GET THREE
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH.
SEEING NONE.
ASSUMING THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
PRESENT.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YES MISS OBERNOLTE I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MISTER MULLIN.
BOB GREAT BILL I'M PROUD TO
SUPPORT A DAY I HAD A QUESTION --
I'VE I WAS VERY FAMILIAR WITH
SHORT MESSAGE SERVICES BUT NOT
VERY FAMILIAR WITH REAL TIME
MESSAGING SERVICE.
AND I WONDERED WHY YOUR BILL
DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEMS ACCEPTED BOTH RATHER
THAN JUST ONE OF THE OTHER.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE THE REAL
TIME MESSAGING SERVICE WOULD BE
SOMETHING MUCH MORE USEFUL TO
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND SO
I DON'T EVEN.
SEE ANY REASON WHY ARE NINE ONE
ONE DISPATCHER SHOULDN'T BE
REQUIRED TO RESPOND TO EITHER
ONE OF THEM RATHER THAN JUST ONE
OF THE OTHER.
WALT THANK YOU WERE SELLING AND
I'M CERTAINLY OPEN TO THAT AND I
WILL MOST CERTAINLY LOOK AT THAT
THE GOAL HERE IS TO EXPAND
ACCESS -- ENTIRELY IF WE IF WE
GET OPEN THAT UP IT DOESN'T
CREATE TOUGH ALL SORTS OF UP --
ISSUES WITH ACTUALLY GETTING
THIS ACROSS THE FINISH LINE AND
MOST CERTAINLY WILL ENTERTAIN
THAT I DON'T KNOW WITH -- MY
WITNESS HAS ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENT JUST ON THAT SPECIFIC
ISSUE SINCE SHE'S BEEN IMMERSED
IN THIS.
TOPIC.
FCC IS RICK IS RECOMMENDING THAT
WE INCLUDE.
THE ABILITY THAT WE HAVE
TECHNOLOGY CAPABLE OF BOTH SO IN
CLUB REAL TIME CAPTIONING AND
ALSO AS WELL AS TEXT.
AS WELL AND SO INTO WE GET TO
THE NEXT GENERATION OF NINE ONE
ONE THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND
SEEN NONE.
OF WHICH I'VE CLOSE WAS MULLIN.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
AND JUST WANT TO EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE.
TO THE DEAF AND HARD HARD OF
HEARING COMMUNITY WHO HAVE BEEN
ACTIVE ON A NUMBER OF BILLS --
THAT WE'VE CARRIED THANK THEM --
FOR MAKING THEIR WAY TO THE
CAPITAL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN ADULT.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN -- THIS
BILL WILL BE TAKEN UP A ONCE
THERE'S A QUORUM THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
SEE MR LEVINE IN THE AUDIENCE
WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT TO
SUBCOMMITTEE.
MR LOOK MISTER LIVING YOU WERE
HERE EARLIER -- FOR SOME
HOUSEKEEPING.
WE HAD SAID THAT THEY WOULD BE
THREE WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN YEAH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN NINETY NINE WHICH WILL
PROHIBIT A MOBILE INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDER.
FROM IMPAIRING OR DEGRADING.
A THE LAWFUL INTERNET TRAFFIC OF
EMERGENCY -- OF ITS PUBLIC
SAFETY CUSTOMER ACCOUNTS DURING
A DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY
WHEN RESPONDING TO DECLARE A
STATE OF EMERGENCY PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL MAY UTILIZE THE
STATEWIDE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM. TO
REQUEST ASSISTANCE FROM PUBLIC
SAFETY DEPARTMENTS IN
NEIGHBORING JURISDICTIONS.
THE EFFECTIVE DEPLOYMENT OF THE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM REQUIRES A
HIGH DEGREE OF COORDINATION
BETWEEN DEPARTMENTS IN REAL TIME
UPDATES THE A SPECIALIZED
COMMUNICATIONS EQUIPMENT.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY FIRE OFFICIALS COMBAT IN
THE MENDOCINO COMPLEX FIRES
EXPERIENCE DATA THROTTLING OTHER
COMMUNICATIONS EQUIPMENT WITH
THIS EQUIPMENT SLOWED TO A CRAWL
THEY WERE FORCED TO CON.
CONTACT YOUR PROVIDERS CUSTOMER
SERVICE DEPARTMENT IN AN ATTEMPT
TO RESOLVE THE ISSUE THEY WERE
MET WITH AN OFFER TO UPGRADE
THEIR SERVICE.
THERE'S EXISTING PLAN IN ORDER
TO LIFT THE RESTRICTIONS AS
NOTED BY ANTHONY ABOUT IN THE
COUNTY'S FIRE CHIEF THE
THROTTLING HAD A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON THEIR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY SERVICES.
AND IMPEDED THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE CRISIS RESPONSE AN
ESSENTIAL EMERGENCY SERVICES.
IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
STATE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL WITH FULLY FUNCTIONING
EQUIPMENT.
AND WHILE STEPS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
BY PROVIDERS TO NEGATE REPEAT
SITUATION AB SIXTEEN NINETY NINE
WILL ENSURE THE DATA THROTTLING
OF PEP OF PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS EQUIPMENT.
IS NEVER REPEATED.
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS ERNESTO FALCON
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL FOR LIKE
TRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION AND
CHIEF JEFF MASTON PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
SHE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE OFF.
CERTAINLY A GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COUNCIL THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
WHEN WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT FIRE
EVENTS OR ANY DISASTERS RIGHT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE USE THAT
CALIFORNIA MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
WHICH IS PROBABLY THE MOST
ROBUST ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD?
THE USE OF A TELEPHONE AND
INTERNET COMMUNICATIONS IS
CRITICAL FOR US TO BE ABLE TO DO
OUR JOBS -- AS WE FOUND OUT FROM
OUR COLLEAGUES IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY FIRE -- THEY HAD AN ISSUE
WITH THROTTLING -- THAT REALLY
WAS DETRIMENTAL WHEN WE GO INTO
EMERGENCY INCIDENT WE ARE REALLY
ALL ABOUT TRYING TO GET
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
DETERMINING WHERE WE'RE GOING
WITH THE MAPPING LOOKS LIKE --
PITCHERS OF FIRE ACTIVITY OF WHO
IS WORKING AND WHAT DIVISION ONE
GROUPS ALTHOUGH WE HAVE RADIOS
WE ALSO REALLY RELY ON OUR
ACTUALLY TELEPHONE SYSTEMS.
SO THE BOTTOM LINE PRESSURES
WERE VERY SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND WE'RE THANKFUL THAT THE
AUTHORS BROUGHT IT FORWARD --
THIS IS CRITICAL IN THIS STATE
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO UTILIZE
THAT AND WE WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I CHAIR SANTIAGO BY CHERYL WITH
OR WITHOUT THE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
MY NAME'S EARNEST ABOUT GOING ON
THE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL FOR THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION --
THE SUCH A PROBLEM BEFORE STEMS
FROM THE FACT THAT THE FCC THE
PRO COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION NO
LONGER DOES THE JOB IN
OVERSEEING THE PRIVATE INDUSTRY.
AND UNDER THE RESTORING INNER
FREEDOM ORDER.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THEREFORE
THE STATE MUST DO MORE TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC INTEREST IS PROTECTED
ON ISSUES SUCH AS PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE OTHER SIGNALED IN ITS
LITIGATION OVER OVER ITS
DECISION TO ABANDON OVERSIGHT
BUT THEY REALLY DO NOT THINK
THAT DEREGULATION WOULD CAUSE
IMPACTS ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
IT'S A CLARA COUNTY'S COUNCIL A
PARTY TO THAT LITIGATION.
REFUTED THIS CLAIM INCORRECTLY
CHARACTERIZED THAN APPROACH TO
WAIT UNTIL AFTER THE FACT WHEN
THESE ISSUES HAPPENED RATHER
THAN GETTING AHEAD IS
ESSENTIALLY SAYING THE REGULAR
WILL WAIT TILL.
ARE DEAD BEFORE ACTING.
MAKE NO MISTAKE WHAT HAPPENED IN
SANTA CLARA IS THAT THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT THERE HAD NOTHING TO
DO OF ENGINEERING AND NOTHING TO
DO OF NETWORK HAS CITY HAD
NOTHING TO DO OF ANY SORT
TECHNICAL RATIONALE.
THERE ARE NO GOOD REASONS FOR
FIRE DEPARTMENTS BROADBAND
SERVICE TO BE THROTTLED DOWN TO
ONE TWO HUNDREDTH OF ITS
ORIGINAL SPEED IN THE MIDDLE OF
EMERGENCY RENDER IT USELESS.
AND THEN ASKING THEM FOR MORE
MONEY AFTER FOUR WEEKS OF A GO
AROUND.
SUCH CONDUCT WOULD HAVE BEEN
ILLEGAL UNDER THE FCC TWENTY
FIFTEEN OPEN IN ORDER AND ITS
BAN ON ON JUSTIN ON REGIONAL
PRACTICES.
I'M NOT SAYING YOUR VERIZON
PLOTTED TO DO HARM BUT I AM
SAYING THAT THERE IS NO
GOVERNMENT ENTITY TODAY WITH THE
GOAL OF BALANCING OF THE PROFIT
MOTIVE FROM OTHER IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATIONS SUCH AS PUBLIC
SAFETY. TO GET AHEAD OF THESE
PROBLEMS.
NOW THERE'S NOTHING CONFUSING
ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION IS
NOTHING VAGUER AMBIGUOUS ABOUT
THE TERMS OF AB SIXTY NINETY
NINE THEY COME STRAIGHT FROM THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER.
AT WHICH HAS BEEN SUBJECT TO
VETTING BY NUMBER OF EXPERTS AND
I DON'T SEE ANY TECHNICAL REASON
WHY THE WIRELESS CARRIERS ARE
ABLE TO MEET THE GOALS OF THIS
LEGISLATION PERFECT VERIZON'S
ALREADY COMMITTED ON ITS OWN.
AFTER ADMITTING WRONG TO DO SO.
SO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY HERE EFF URGES AND I'VE
ON THIS LEGISLATION AND I LOOK
FOR ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY MAIN OPPOSITION.
I APOLOGIZE I IS HE THAT WOULD
BE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITIONALLY.
YES SANDERS REPRESENTING THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
FORMALLY THE OFFICER REPAIR
ADVOCATES AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN NINETY
NINE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I TRACY ROSENBERG.
I'M FROM MEDIA ALLIANCE AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON REGION ACOSTA WAS
TURN THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT --
GOOD AFTERNOON MISS SHARE
RUSSELL NOVAK ON BEHALF OF THE
FIRE DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU SEEN NO ADDITIONAL
WITH THE SUPPORT MAIN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES.
MR CHEN MEMBERS STEVE CARLSON
FOR CTIA THE WIRELESS
ASSOCIATION WE'VE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH THE
PHILIPPINES OFFICE -- WE WE
THINK THIS CAN BE WORKED OUT --
WANTED -- TO ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS UNDERSTAND THAT THE THAT
THE INCIDENT THAT -- HAS GIVEN
RISE TO THIS WAS THAT YOU IN OUR
IT WAS -- RECTIFIED -- WAS NOT
INTENTIONAL IT WAS NOT THE AND
AND IT ALSO DESPITE WITH ONE OF
THE WITNESSES WHO SAID IT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH NET
NEUTRALITY -- AS THE AT THE
ANALYSIS I THINK GAP ADEQUATELY
POINTS OUT -- THE BILL WAS
AMENDED WE APPRECIATED THE
AMENDMENT THAT HAD SOME --
LANGUAGE BUT WHICH WAS VERY
TROUBLING AT THE BEGINNING --
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO THINK THAT
THERE ARE SOME SPECIFICS IN HERE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THE EMERGENCY TRIGGER HOW
DOES A CARRIER KNOW.
WHEN THERE IS AN EMERGENCY --
HOW ARE THEY NOTIFIED WHEN THERE
IS AN EMERGENCY -- IF IT'S A
VERY LOCALIZED SITUATION -- THAT
CREATES COMPLICATIONS -- THE
INDUSTRY NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND AND
KNOW.
WHEN AND WHERE THEIR OBLIGATIONS
OF APPLY -- AND I THINK THAT
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH MISTER
LEVINE -- TO TO WORK OUT -- I DO
THINK IMPAIR INTEGRATE IMPAIR OR
DEGRADE DOES HAVE SOME -- HAVE --
HAS SOME AMBIGUITY TO IT IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY THE IMPAIRED TO
GREAT THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH.
THAT NEUTRALITY AGAIN AS THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT WHICH IS THE
IMPAIR DEGREE BECAUSE OF CONTENT
THIS HAS TO DO WITH DATA -- SO
FOR THOSE REASONS.
WE ARE A OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
BUT BUT AGAIN WANTED WORK THIS
THROUGH AND I THINK THAT THERE
IS A I THINK THERE'S A WAY TO
RESOLVE THIS UP.
ANY ADDIIONAL OF OPPOSITION
WITNESSES.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
WHICH OBERNOLTE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
CINNAMON I THINK THIS A GREAT
BILL -- BOB HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM I DO HAVE
A PART OF THE BILL THOUGH THAT I
FOUND A LITTLE PUZZLING THAT I
THOUGHT YOU MIGHT.
SHED SOME LIGHT ON THEIR TWO
SECTIONS THE BILL SECTION TWO IS
ACT THE SECTION THAT ACTUALLY.
IMPLEMENTS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE AND SECTION ONE JUST HAS
SOME FINDINGS AND THE FIRST
STATEMENT IN SECTION ONE IS.
THE LEGISLATURE FINDS AND
DECLARES THAT THIS ACT IS
ADOPTED PURSUANT TO THE POLICE
POWER GRANTED TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
UNDER THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION AND CANNOT BE
PREEMPTED BY THE FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION.
I FOUND THAT VERY PUZZLING
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE NICE IF WE
COULD DECLARE WHAT COULD AND
COULD NOT BE FEDERALLY PREEMPTED
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THAT AUTHORITY
OR THAT ABILITY ONLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES AND THEY DECIDE
WHAT GETS PREEMPTED SO.
I WONDERED WHY THAT STATEMENTS
IN THERE AND AND BECAUSE IT TO
ME IT'S NONSENSICAL.
WE CAN WORK WITH LEDGE COUNCIL
TO HELP YOU UNDERSTAND THAT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT BALK IT DID JUST THAT
RAISE MY EYEBROWS WHEN I READ IT
BUT I I I THINK MANY OF US ARE
OFTEN ENTERTAINED BY THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE RECEIVE FROM
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL RIGHT.
OKAY WELL -- THANKS AND HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL --
QUESTIONS FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
QUESTION.
A SCENE.
NINE THIS WILL BE WHICH I CLOSE.
I THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THE COMMITTEE -- TO
THE STAKEHOLDERS BOTH OF THOSE --
IN SUPPORT NATURALLY BUT BUT
EVEN THOSE WHO -- ARE OPPOSED TO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
POLICY ACTUALLY WORKS THAT WERE
ABLE TO KEEP CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY SAFE -- WE KNOW --
THAT WE'RE NOT OUT OF OUR OUR
LAST DISASTER THAT THERE BEFORE
US WE WANNA MAKE SURE WILL TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
ARE SUB CLASS FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN THE BILL COMES BEFORE YOU.
THE THE MEASURE ENJOYS A DO
PASSED -- IT TO COMMITTEE ON
PRIVACY BUT WE WILL NOT TAKE UP
UNTIL THERE IS A A QUORUM.
THANK YOU -- MISTER WOULD LIKE
PERCENT.
WE STATED EARLIER MISTER WHEN
THERE WERE ALLOWING THREE
WITNESSES. TWO MINUTES EACH FOR
AND AGAINST.
THANK YOU -- GOOD AFTERNOON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB FIVE TWO
THREE TWO THIS AFTERNOON.
THIS BILL IS IN RESPONSE TO
TROUBLING INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALISM THAT I'M COVERED THE
PRACTICE OF CELL PHONE COMPANIES
SELLING SENSITIVE SUBSCRIBER
DATA.
MOST CONCERNING REAL TIME
LOCATION DATA AND THIS IS
DIFFERENT THEN THE GPS STATE ON
YOUR PHONE THE APPS THAT ARE
TRACKING YOU THIS IS CELL.
TOWER DATA THEY USE
TRIANGULATION.
TO FIGURE OUT LOCATION THIS
INFORMATION WAS AND PACKAGED AND
RESOLD. TO ANYBODY WILLING TO
PAY USUALLY BOUNTY HUNTERS AND
OTHERS WITH AN INTEREST IN
FINDING AND STOCKING INDIVIDUALS
IN NEAR REAL TIME.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE SAME
INFORMATION.
IS ONLY AVAILABLE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH A SEARCH
WARRANT.
AND IT'S AN IMPORTANT PROTECTION
DUE TO THE HIGHLY SENSITIVE
NATURE OF YOUR LOCATION FEDERAL
LAW AND REGULATIONS HAVE CLEARLY
REQUIRE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES TO PROTECT THIS DATA
HAD TO SHARED ONLY WITH
SUBSCRIBERS CONSENT.
HOWEVER THE ONLY FEDERAL
ENFORCER IS THE FCC AND IT'S
FAILED TO HOLD
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
ACCOUNTABLE.
AFTER THIS CONDUCT WAS UNCOVERED
LAST SUMMER EVERY MAJOR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS CEO COMMITTED
TO ENDING THE PRACTICE GET EVEN
MORE INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALISM
WAS STILL ABLE TO OBTAIN REAL
TIME LOCATION.
OF A REPORTERS OWN CELL PHONE
THIS IN JANUARY THIS BILL
MAHER'S THE RESTRICTIONS ALREADY
PRESENT IN FEDERAL LAW UPDATING
DECADES OLD CALIFORNIA
PROTECTIONS THAT WERE ENACTED
WHEN LANDLINES WERE THE ONLY
FORM OF COMMUNICATION.
WITH AB FIVE TWO THREE
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE ABLE TO
HOLD THESE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
CEOS TO THEIR WORD AND NOT HAVE
TO WAIT UNTIL THE FCC DECIDES TO
DO ITS JOB.
I'M PLEASED TO HAVE WITH ME
TODAY -- TERRACE DíAS ANDREAS
FROM THE P. UC'S PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE TO SPEAK THANK
YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AT THIS ADDRESS --
FROM THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE FORMALLY THE OFFICE
REPAIR ADVOCATES -- WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE TWENTY THREE
WHICH WOULD STRENGTH AND PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS FOR CUSTOMERS OF
WIRELESS PROVIDERS -- THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE WIRES WIRELESS
CARRIERS TO OBTAIN WRITTEN
CONSENT FROM THEIR CUSTOMERS
BEFORE THEY SHARE OR SELL THAT
CUSTOMERS INFORMATION REAL TIME.
LOCATION INFORMATION TO OTHER
INDIVIDUALS OR BUSINESSES --
ALTHOUGH WIRELESS CARRIERS CLAIM
THAT THEY DO NOT SO CUSTOMERS
GEO LOCATION DATA -- RECENT
GUEST INVESTIGATIONS -- HAVE
SHOWN THAT THAT STATEMENT IS
COMPLETELY FALSE.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
WOULD HELP PAYING INTO THIS
PRACTICE AND STRENGTHEN PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS FOR CUSTOMERS WHICH
THEY CRIED THEY DESERVE.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ANY ADDITIONAL --
WITNESSES PORT.
THERE'S ANY -- ME TO USE.
NAME ORGANIZATION -- VIRGIN
ACOSTA RETURN WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ANY MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE
AGAIN -- STEVE CARLSON CTIA THE
WIRELESS ASSOCIATION WE'VE BEEN
IN CONVERSATION WITH -- WITH MS
OR WHEN AND AND HER STAFF AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING ON SOME
CONCERNS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE A MAYBE SOME --
CLARIFICATION ON ON OF SORT OF
WHAT HAPPENED.
THE INFORMATION WAS PROVIDED TO
MIDDLE MAN -- DATA AGGREGATORS
FORK LARGELY THE PURPOSE.
OF PROVIDING FOR ROADSIDE
ASSISTANCE FRAUD PROTECTION AND
THOSE THAT INFORMATION -- WHEN
IT WAS DISCOVERED THAT IT WAS
BEING USED FOR OTHER PURPOSES --
BUT THE COMPANIES -- DECIDED
THAT THEY NEEDED TO STOP THAT --
AND THEY HAVE AND MIGHT HAVE
HAPPENED AS FAST AS WE WOULD
LIKE TO AND AND BUT IT BUT IT
HAS -- AND THEY'RE NOT PROVIDING
ANY OF THAT. TO TO THE POINT
THAT THE INFORMATION ABOUT FOR
ROADSIDE ASSISTANCE AND FRAUD IS
NO LONGER BEING PROVIDED SO.
IF THE INTENT WAS THE WAS THE
YOU KNOW WAS A WAS A THAT.
WAS A GOOD -- ONE IT BECAUSE THE
THIS INFORMATION THAT HELPS
PEOPLE BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT THE
THE USE OF THAT INFORMATION AND
IN WAYS THAT WE HADN'T TO
ANTICIPATED BUT IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT -- WE SUPPORT --
WE THINK THAT THERE IS POTENTIAL
FOR A CONFUSION WITH -- C. C. P.
AGE YOUR LOCATION IS A PART OF
THE CALIFORNIA -- CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT AND WHO DOES TO MS
IRWIN BECAUSE SHE'S A SHE'S A
WARRIOR ON THAT DONE ON A ON A
LOT OF FRONTS AND SO -- YOU SEE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTANDS WHAT WE
THINK THAT TO SOME ISSUES THERE
THAT WE'D LIKE.
TO LIKE TO CLARIFY.
WE ALSO WOULD LIKE THE COMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER.
THAT IT SHOULD BE THE WALKED AND
NOT THE WHO THAT IS BEING --
DEALT WITH HERE -- THERE ARE
OTHER.
TECHNOLOGIES THAT USE THE SAME
TYPE OF INFORMATION -- CELL SITE
INFORMATION LIKE THIS IS THE GPS
AND THE LIKE -- AND WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT.
ALL THE DATA THAT'S SIMILARLY
SITUATED SHOULD BE -- DEALT WITH
THE SAME WAY -- MIND OF YOU OF
THE TIMING.
WELL I GUESS SIX MINUTES RIGHT.
COULD NOT GET [inaudible]
THIS KID.
I'M ALMOST FINISHED -- BUT WELL
ANYWAY.
YOU GET THE THEN I THINK THAT
THE OTHER POINT OF CONFUSION IS
THAT IT IT IT ACTUALLY HAS BEEN
PUT INTO A CODE SECTION THAT'S
THAT'S ALSO HAS FEDERAL
IMPLICATIONS I THOUGHT SO I
THINK THERE'S CONFUSION -- THAT
COULD RESULT FROM THIS WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT
THE GOAL IS WE SUPPORT THE GOAL
OF THE SAME INFORMATION BEING
TREATED THE SAME WAY -- AND WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT
WITH MR WENT SO -- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
ANY QUESTION FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- YES MISS
KAMLAGER-DOVE FOLLOWED BY MISTER
GIBSON THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO
MISS IRWIN WAS YOU MENTIONED --
SOME INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING
THAT HAD AND COVERED THIS.
WAS THIS -- THE ARTICLE THAT WAS
IN THE NEW YORK TIMES THAT
REALLY SHOWED OUT ONCE --
INFORMATION WAS OBTAINED THEY
WERE IN FACT TRACKING CHILDREN --
ON THEIR WAY TO SCHOOL AND COULD
DETERMINE HOW LONG THEY WERE IN
SCHOOL AND WHERE THEY WERE GOING
AFTERWARDS.
THEY WERE TRACKING OR ABLE TO
TRACK WHEN A SOMEONE WAS GOING
TO VISIT THEIR DOCTOR -- A
NUMBER OF INSTANCES WHERE
PRIVATE -- SPACES YOU COULD
ARGUE WERE BEING VIOLATED IS IT
THAT SAME ARTICLE AS IT IS
ABSOLUTELY THAT SAME DISTURBING
ARTICLE.
OKAY THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO
GET CLARIFICATION BECAUSE I
FOUND THAT TO BE INCREDIBLY
DISTURBING AND FOR FOLKS WHO MAY
BE -- AND VIOLENCE SITUATIONS
ARE CHILDREN WHO ARE UNDER AGE --
AND THEIR PRIVACY NEEDS TO BE
PROTECTED -- IT REALLY WASN'T
ALARMING -- INDICATION OF HOW WE
CAN DO MORE TO PROTECT PRIVACY
SO THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I KNOW MISS UP
TODAY.
OF A FINE IS IN THIS TOPIC VERY
INTERESTING I WANT A ONE
APPRECIATED THANK THE OFFER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- BASED
ON THE COMMENTS I LIVE MY
COMMENTS -- WITH THE SAME
CONCERNS THAT -- MISS COME LIKE
A JOB JUST EXPRESSING MOMENTS
AGO REGARDING THE ARTICLE CAN
YOU JUST TALK ABOUT VERY BRIEFLY
IN TERMS OF ONE THE WRITTEN
PARKS THAT NEEDS TO BE OBTAINED
IF YOU CAN -- FOR TO OPT YEAH I
GUESS IS TO OPT OUT.
OF SUCH AND THEN ALSO.
IT WAS THE THING MISS CARSON
MADE MENTION ABOUT A GREAT AREA
THAT SEEMINGLY COULD BE VERY
OFTEN TO THE FEDERAL --
REGULATIONS OR HAVE JURISDICTION
AT AREA.
SO -- CURRENTLY THIS IN.
THE USERS ARE NOT OPTING IN ARE
OPTING OUT TO THIS INFORMATION
IT WAS JUST BEING SOLD TO DATA
BROKERS WHO SOLD IT TO BOUNTY
HUNTERS AND SO THAT WOULD BE THE
FIRST THING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT PEOPLE.
IF THEY WANT THEIR CELL PHONE
INFORMATION REAL TIME LOCATION
INFORMATION SOLD.
THAN THEY NEEDED -- TO OFTEN TO
THAT.
THE GRAY AREA THIS IS THIS IS
BASICALLY THIS IS KIND OF THE
SAME AS WHAT WHAT WHAT WE HAVE
WITH LAND LINES WE HAVE -- WE
HAVE FEDERAL LEGISLATION AND
THEN WE HAVE THE SAME THING
MIRRORED IN IT AND AT THE C. P.
U. C. THIS WOULD DO THE SAME
THING NOW IT'S MY MOBILE
INFORMATION IS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND REGULATED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WHERE THIS IS
ALREADY.
NOT ALLOWED SO WE WOULD MAYOR
THAT IN CALIFORNIA CODE AND THAT
THERE WOULD BE A PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION ON THAT -- AND AT THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO ONE OF THE OTHER --
THE OPPOSITION'S OTHER ISSUES
WAS A WHY SHOULDN'T THIS OF THE
COVER OF YOU KNOW CABLE
COMPANIES AND AND OTHER.
DATA COMPANIES THAT MIGHT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE CELL PHONE
INFORMATION THIS IS REALLY JUST
DEALING WITH.
THE PLAYERS THAT WORD.
DOING THE BAD ACT NOW -- SO WE
DON'T WANT TO BRING EVERYBODY
INTO IT WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HOLD THE CEOS TO
THEIR PROMISES WHICH WAS.
THAT THEY WERE NOT GOING TO BE
SELLING THIS REAL TIME OR NEAR
REAL TIME INFORMATION TO A DATA
BROKERS UNLESS YOU EXPLICITLY
AGREE TO IT.
I THINK THE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION THIS CROSS AND
INDICATED THAT THERE HE DID TO
DESCRIBE THAT THE INCIDENT DID
IN FACT HAPPEN THERE'S A MIDDLE
MAN THAT DID IT.
AND THEY'RE QUICKLY TRY TO
ADDRESSED IT ADDRESSES SO
WOULDN'T HAPPEN AGAIN -- AND AND
WE A KNOWLEDGE OF THAT COMPANY
HAS TAKEN THAT KIND OF
LEADERSHIP BUT THERE'S OTHER
COMPANIES.
WHO -- POTENTIALLY COULD BE
DOING THIS AS WELL THAT WE ARE
UNAWARE OF IN THIS BILL WILL OF
COURSE ADDRESS.
A NUMBER OF THOSE ISSUES
OUTSTANDING CORRECT AND AND THEY
AGREED NOT TO DO IT BUT THEN --
THAT WAS A SECOND ARTICLE THAT
AT THAT THAT THAT IT HAD BEEN
DONE AGAIN.
BY THE SAME COMPANY -- OR
ANOTHER COMPANY.
YEAH THAT'S IT THAT'S IT IN IN
GENERAL THE REPORTER WAS ABLE TO
FIND THEIR THEY WERE ABLE TO BUY
THEIR LOCATION DATA AFTER THIS
ARTICLE CAME OUT SO -- I KNOW
EVERYBODY MEANS WELL MAYBE IT
TAKES A LONG TIME TO WIND ALL
THIS DOWN BUT AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALL LONGER DOES
MENTIONED WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
POTENTIALLY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
VICTIMS -- BEING FOLLOWED IN
REAL TIME BY THEIR ABUSERS
THAT'S HIGHLY PROBLEMATIC SO WE
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- FOR
LEADING INTHIS SPACE AND I KNOW
THE CYBERSECURITY YOU'VE BEEN A
YOU KNOW A TRAILBLAZER IN THIS
AREA AND AND CERTAINLY --
CONTINUE ON IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO BRING THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION OB ACCORDING TODAY.
IT'S SOMETHING THEN THEY GIVE
THIS QUIRK SILVA FOLLOWED BY MR
OBERNOLTE.
YEAH AGAIN THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN FOR YOUR
WORK IN THIS AREA -- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT -- I THINK THAT
WOULD BE VERY INTERESTING FOR
THE PUBLIC IS BECAUSE SOME OF
THE ISSUES YOU'VE TALKED TO US
ABOUT AND BILLS YOU BROUGHT
FORWARD.
RELATED TO CYBERSECURITY AND
MANY OTHERS.
IS THEY HAVE ABOUT.
A VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
INFORMATION OF RELATED TO WHAT
THEY'RE GIVING OUT AND WHAT'S
BEING USED.
SO I THINK IT COULD BE A REALLY --
EXCELLENT OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND THAT IF
PERHAPS THROUGH -- OUR DISTRICT
OFFICES WE COULD HOLD SOME --
SOME TYPE OF INFORMATIONAL --
AND WORKSHOPS ON THAT.
SO THAT'S JUST A COMMENT ON IT
BECAUSE THIS ISRAEL AREA IN
FULLER TEN OF NOT TOO LONG AGO
ABOUT TWO TO THREE YEARS AGO --
THERE WAS A CASE OF THAT THE
POLICE WERE INVOLVED THROUGH CAL
STATE FULLERTON WHERE -- A MAN
WAS TRACKING A YOUNG LADIES
THROUGH THEIR GPS.
ON A LINE KNOWING WHERE THEY
WERE.
NOT GOING AFTER THEM BUT GOING
TO WHERE THEY LIVED.
AND WAS ABLE TO GET INTO THEIR
APARTMENTS AND ACTUALLY ****
PERSONAL ITEMS AND THEY FOUND.
THAT HE WAS NOT ONLY DOING THAT
AT CAL STATE FULLERTON BUT ALSO
CHAPMAN COLLEGE.
AND THEY PUT THE INFORMATION
TOGETHER AND IT TURNED OUT.
THEY WERE ABLE TO CONVICT HIM OF
HE WHEN THEY WENT TO HIS RIGHT
IS RESIDENT HE HAD SOME -- MANY
MANY BAGS OF IF YOU WANT TO CALL
AND PANTIES.
HE WAS CALLED THE PANTY SNATCHER
BUT OF THE GIRLS ACTUALLY.
IT WAS SOMETHING THEY DIDN'T
REALLY NOTICE TO BUT HE WAS
THERE AND THIS IS RESET THIS IS
JUST LIKE TWO YEARS AGO AND
FULLER TEN AND CHECK OUT MAN.
AND HE WAS ABLE TO GET IN AND
KNOW WHERE THEY WERE BY THE
INFORMATION THEY PROVIDED.
SO --I APPRECIATE THIS BILL
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT -- THESE ARE
REAL -- SCENARIOS THANK YOU AND
AND THE I. APPRECIATE ALWAYS THE
CHANCE TO BE ABLE TO EDUCATE
EVERYBODY ABOUT MAKING SUE THAT
OF WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL YOUR
APPS.
MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE LOCATION
SERVICES OFFER ALL THOSE THAT
REALLY DON'T NEED YOUR LOCATION
SERVICES AND AND THERE HAS.
CERTAINLY RECENTLY BEEN A STORY
ABOUT. ONE APP THAT WAS SELLING
OF ALL YOUR LOCATION INFORMATION
AFTER THE FACT TWO OF MANY MANY
DATA BROKERS AND AND AGAIN WE
NEED TO BE AWARE AS OF CAN AS
CONSUMERS.
THAT WE HAVE CONTROL OVER THE
GPS THE DATA THAT'S ON OUR
PHONES.
I WANNA HOLD JUST ONE SECOND
WHAT WE GOT OF MEMBERS HERE
ESTABLISH REQUIREMENTS SECRETARY.
IN A GET THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
IT.
IS THAT WHAT IS ACCEPTED FORM
THAT I TWENTY YES.
UNLESS YOU WANT THAT THAT'S
WE'RE TRYING TO DO MAKE SURE
WITHOUT A QUORUM [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
HERE OBERNOLTE.
BUT A WHOLE THAT [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
COPS OVER.
HERE.
RODRIGUEZ.
BUT WE HAVE A CORNER STATUS CAN
WE MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
THE TWO BILLS ON CONSENT
CALENDAR THAT WERE PUT ON BY
ANONYMOUS CONSENT.
IT WOULD BE A. B. -- NINE FIFTY
SIX BY DIP AND AB FORTINO NINE
BY CHAO WE HAVE A MOTION WITH
THE SECOND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION FOR A BI NINE FIFTY
SIX IS TO PROCESS AMENDED.
TO PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION ON CONSENT.
AB FORTINO NINE TO PAUSE TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS ON
CONSENT [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I BUT A WHOLE VAT.
BUT A WHOLE THAT I BONTA
[inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON I HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I LOW.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ SIDE.
IT IS A IT IS YOUR CONSENT
CALENDARS OUT -- SORRY FOR THE
INTERRUPTION.
MR ONE BUT YOU MAY CONTINUE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS I THINK IT
WAS MR OBERNOLTE WAS NEXT.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO -- I
I TELL YOU I'M REALLY ON THE
FENCE ON THIS BILL BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO AND MY QUESTION IS.
IS TO DOES CURRENT STATE LAW AND
FEDERAL LAW ALREADY ACCOMPLISH
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
I UNDERSTAND YOU TO SAY NO SO
I'VE I'VE JUST GOT A COUPLE
QUESTIONS IF I COULD BIG THE
COMMITTEE'S INDULGENCE BECAUSE
I'M TRYING TO GET TO A YES HERE --
THAT IF WE CAN GET MISTER
CARLSON BACK UP I'VE GOT A
QUESTION FOR HIM AS WELL.
SO. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
BEEN ASSERED IS THAT THIS MIGHT
TO RATE CONFUSION BECAUSE UNDER
CURRENT STATE PRIVACY LAW
THERE'S A RITE OF OPT OUT.
AND THIS WOULD CREATE A RITE OF
OPT IN AND THE QUESTION HAS BEEN
RAISED IF A CONSUMER WERE TO OPT
IN IN ONE PLACE AND OUT ON THE
OTHER PLACE -- WOULD NOT CREATE
SO -- SOME CONFUSION ON THE PART
OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANY AS
TO WHAT TO DO WITH THAT
INFORMATION.
OKAY SO IT'S A PART OF THE CODE
THAT ALREADY EXISTS FOR THE LAND
LINE BA YEAH YEAH.
I KNOW IT AT THAT IF YOU SEE
CODE.
ARE NO I'M TALKING ABOUT THE C.
CPA.
SINCE THIS IS DIGITAL
INFORMATION.
OUT AND I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THAT WE CAN DAVID THIS FOR
CARLSON CAN [inaudible]
AND AND THREE FIVE AND I KNOW
THE CHAIR -- I'M SORRY THE
AUTHOR WILL BE ANSWERED A LOT OF
THESE QUESTIONS AND AND PRIVACY.
AS WELL SO THE BEING MORE OF
THAT AREA IT'S BUT NONE THE LESS
YOU OF WHAT WILL GET BACK TO YOU
ON ITS -- IT'S THE SAME CONFLICT
THAT WILL EXIT THAT EXISTS FOR
THE LAND LINE ALSO.
SO I THINK YOU SAID WAS MOST
RECENT -- ACTION.
OKAY WELL WHAT.
WE'LL BE SEEING IT AGAIN PRIVACY
SO TWIX NOW AND THEN -- IF YOU
CAN TOTAL DOWN ON THAT I'D
APPRECIATE IT -- DEFINITELY WELL
THANK YOU SO.
ANOTHER MR CARSON THIS QUESTION
FOR YOU ANOTHER QUESTION A
ANOTHER -- ASSERTION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THAT'S
BEEN RAISED IS THAT FEDERAL
TELECOMMUNICATIONS LAWS ALREADY
PREVENTS.
NON ANONYMIZED DATA FROM BEING
SOLD.
AND OP I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT I
WONDER HOW IT IS THAT.
THIS DATA COULD HAVE BEEN SOLD
TO A MIDDLE MAN IN A FORMAT THAT.
ALLOW THEM TO BE OF USE TO
SOMEONE LIKE A PARTY HOW TO OR
EVEN A ROADSIDE ASSISTANCE
COMPANY IF THAT WERE TRUE --
THERE ARE SOME EXCEPTIONS -- TO
THAT TO THAT RULE AND I I THERE
ARE LIMITATIONS RIGHT -- USING
STORED COMMUNICATIONS
INFORMATION TO YOUR LOCATION --
I THINK AT THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN -- GENERAL GEOLOCATION
IMPRECISE YOUR LOCATION -- IN
THIS INSTANCE I THINK WHAT THEY
DO IS THEY CAN TAKE THAT AND%
THEN ADD MORE INTO A TO TO TRACK
TO TRACK THE INDIVIDUAL BUT I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION -- LET ME GO FURTHER ON
THAT AND GET BACK TO YOU
OKAY.
AND AND OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE F. C. C.'S THAT THAT IS
THE CASE OF BUT THE FCC IS NOT
ENFORCING IT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
I AM LAST QUESTION WOULD BE
CONCERNING THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION WHICH IS SOMETHING I'M
NORMALLY NOT A BIG FAN OF
BECAUSE I THINK WHEN WE SAY THAT
SOMETHING IS ILLEGAL WE HAVE AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT SHOULD BE
ENFORCING THAT.
ESPECIALLY IN THE CASE OF LARGE
CLASSES OF CONSUMERS AND I'D
RATHER LEAVE IT WITH THAT AGENCY
THEY ON CREATE A POSSIBLE PROFIT
MOTIVE FOR PEOPLE TO GO AFTER --
SO IN THIS CASE THAT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT MITIGATES IN MY
OPINION AGAINST THE BILL BUT I
WANTED TO ASK BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT
A SECTION HERE THAT ALLOWS THAT
IT I REALIZE THAT YOU HAVE AN
ADDED TO THAT IT'S WAS CURRENTLY
IN CITY CORD WHICH ARE.
WHICH ARE ADDING THIS PARTICULAR
CLASS OF DATA TO THE THINGS THAT
ARE ACTIONABLE UNDER THAT WHICH
HAS A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
RIGHT SO I'M WONDERING IF
SOMEONE WERE TO BRING SUIT. FOR
DAMAGES WHICH IS ALL THE STATE
COACH RIGHTLY SAYS IS YOU KNOW
THEY CAN RECOVER THEIR DAMAGES
WHAT MIGHT THOSE DAMAGES BE I
MEAN WHAT WHAT ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT WHEN.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ALLOWING
SOMEONE A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION TO SUE.
UP UNDER THIS BILL.
NOW I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY SO I
MEAN I COULD COME UP WITH ALL
SORTS OF IDEAS OF OF WHAT
DAMAGES COULD BE BUT SINCE I'M
NOT AN ATTORNEY I I REALLY WOULD
PREFER TO GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT.
OKAY ALL EITHER IF YOU'RE
HELPING ME MUCH BUT WELL IF YOUR
QUESTIONS ARE ALWAYS VERY
COMPLICATED GOOD NEWS.
GOOD NEWS IS YOU HAVE A
REASONABLE TIME TO DEBATE BEFORE
YOU VOTE ON THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE WITH THE OFF LIKE
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU A MISS IRWIN.
THIS BILL DOES -- ENJOYED DO
PASSED THE COMMITTEE ON PRIVACY
WE WOULD NEED A FIRST AND A
SECOND.
WHEN I FIRST AND A SECOND MAN
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL?
MOTIONS TO PASTA COMMITTEE ON
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING.
BUT A WHOLE THAT.
BUT A WHOLE THAT I BONTA.
BRO.
GIPSON FIVE GIPSON I HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I LOW.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I THERE ARE MUCH OF
SIX ZERO MEASURES ON CALL.
FORGET IT BECAUSE IT'S A BUSY
DAY I'M GONNA TAKE UP TO LIFT
THE CALL FOR MEMBERS HERE CAN
ACTUALLY BUILD ON SOME BILLS
THAT WOULD BE OKAY WITH THE NEXT
UP PRESENTER AS ALWAYS WE GO
SECOND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM THE GAVEL OVER TO FOR JUST
ONE MINUTE.
OKAY.
WE NEED A MOTION ON ITEM FILE
ITEM ONE A. B. ELEVEN SIXTY
EIGHT MULLIN.
J. MOTION A SECOND -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION BY THE WAYS TO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
OBERNOLTE HI OBERNOLTE I BUT A
WHOLE THAT.
BURN A HOLE THAT I BONTA.
BONTA AYE BRO [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON I HOLDEN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
I'M LIKE A DOG I LOW.
PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SEVEN ZERO THE ROLE
SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
I WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
PERHAPS MEMBERS.
I ALSO WILL -- ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
A. B. SIXTEEN NINETY NINE LEVINE.
AS MOTION A SECOND THE MOTION IS.
APPROPRIATIONS I KNOW.
MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PRIVACY MATTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I OBERNOLTE HI.
OBERNOLTE I SPENT A WHOLE Và.
THE NOVEL THAT I BONTA.
ON TO MY BRO.
GIPSON.
GIPSON I HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I LOW.
LISTEN.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ SIGH. TWO ZERO THROWS
A TO ZERO THE MEASURES OUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WE'LL GO TO NEXT BILL -- MRS
ALWAYS MICHIGAN'S ALWAYS YOU'RE
HERE TO PRESENT ON A. B..
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX I JUST SOME
GROUND RULES YOU ARE HERE TO
HEAR THEM EARLIER WILL ALLOW
THREE PRESENTERS ONLY ON EACH
SIDE TWO MINUTES EACH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF A START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS -- AB
[inaudible]
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX CODIFIES
BASICALLY EXISTING LAW FOR
ANOTHER TEN YEARS WE THE REASONS
I TOOK THIS BILL WHITE SO.
IMPORTANT TO ME IS -- THERE ARE.
SERVICES IN MY COMMUNITY THAT
ARE VERY IMPORTANT AND FREE AND
HAVEN'T ALWAYS BEEN -- WE KNOW
ESPECIALLY IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
ABILITY TO CALL HOME -- FOR FREE
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT -- AND
THANKS TO INNOVATIONS AND AND
TECHNOLOGY YOU KNOW AND AND
THINGS LIKE WHAT'S HAPPENED
SKYPE WE NOW HAVE THAT ABILITY
WE NO LONGER HAVE INTERNATIONAL
CALLING CARDS ON ON SEVEN
ELEVEN'S EVERYWHERE AND THAT
THAT IS A HUGE SAVINGS FOR FOR A
COMPANY LIKE MINE.
HOWEVER I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
CONCERNS ABOUT AN AND REGULATES
COMPLETELY UNREGULATED --
RESIDENTIAL VOICE -- SITUATION
AND I JUST WANT TO ALLAY THOSE
CONCERNS WITH A FEW THINGS THAT
I WANT TO ENSURE THAT THAT FOLKS.
WHO ARE GOING TO BE IN
OPPOSITION THAT WE ARE CONTINUE
TO WORK ON WITH THEM?
AT THIS BILL FOR MOVES FORWARD
WE WILL -- CONTINUE TO ADD
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS A WORKER
PROTECTIONS AROUND DISCLOSURE TO
REQUIRE PROVIDER OF WHAT
SERVICES TO DISCLOSE TO CONSUMER
DURING THE SALES TRANSACTION FOR
VOIGTS SERVICES THAT THE
CONSUMER HAS THE RIGHT TO BASIC
TELEPHONE SERVICE -- WE'RE
LOOKING TO HAVE THIS WRITTEN SO
THAT THE CONSUMER COULD CALL THE
QC OR PERHAPS GO TO WEBSITE FOR
MORE INFORMATION REGARDING BASIC
SERVICE.
WE WANT TO ADD -- INSURANCE
ABOUT SERVICE RESTORATION
STANDARDS REQUIRE -- INTER
CONNECTED RESIDENTIAL BOYCHOIR%
LINE TO MEET.
DEFINED STANDARDS OF SERVICE
RESTORATION TIMELINE THE SAME
WAY.
TRADITIONAL PHONES DO.
AND A PERCENTAGE WITHIN THOSE
TIME LINES EXCEPT IN CASES OF
DISASTER OR CASES BEYOND
PROVIDER CONTROL -- PRO RATE AND
SERVICE CREDITS WHEN THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN IN ENFORCEMENT TO
REQUIRE.
THE UC TO SUBMIT A REPORT ABOUT
STANDING NEW COMPLAINTS
REGARDING WHITE AND I P. ENABLE
SERVICES TO THE AG MONTHLY THOSE
ARE SOME OF THINGS WE HOPE TO
WORK ON OVER US.
AS WE MOVE HOPEFULLY MOVE THIS
BILL AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THAT WOULD
BE THREE TWO MINUTES THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE --
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HAS BEEN
DIVIDED AND I AM THE EDUCATIONAL
MANAGER.
OF THE SALVADORAN AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP AND EDUCATIONAL FUND
SALAS.
OUR MISSION IS TO PROMOTE THE
CIVIC PARTICIPATION --
PRESENTATION OF THE LATINO
COMMUNITY IS AN AMERICAN UNITS
IN THE US WE WORK TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA A PLACE WHERE ALL
PEOPLE ENJOY ECONOMICAL SECURITY.
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND POLITICAL
EMPOWERMENT.
I AM HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
LEGISLATION AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
SIX AND TO TALK ABOUT WHY THIS
LEGISLATION IS SO IMPORTANT --
TO LATINO AN IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA LATINO
MOBILE PHONE OWNERSHIP HAS
REACHED AN INCREDIBLE 97% AND
HAS WE HAVE SEEN IN THE RECENT
YEARS NEW TECHNOLOGY APPS AND
SERVICES.
HAVE BEEN LIFE CHANGING FOR THE
LATINO COMMUNITY AND YOU
IMMIGRANTS FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND RECENT
IMMIGRANTS THESE TECHNOLOGIES
AND APPS WITHIN THE PRO PROVIDE
US.
OF LIFELINE AWAY TO CONNECT WHAT
WE LEFT BEHIND.
THEY PROVIDE COMMUNITY FOR THOSE
THAT FEEL ALONE IN YOUR COUNTRY
FOR OTHERS THEY PROVIDE A
GATEWAY TO WORK IN EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR EXAMPLE
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS WHAT'S UP ARE
PROFOUNDLY IMPORTANT TO RECENT
IMMIGRANTS THE STEPS ARE
RELATIVELY NEW SERVICES AND APPS
PROVIDE FREE COMMUNICATION
WILLOW ONCE IN AND ABROAD.
TALK A LITTLE BIT OF PERSONAL --
EXPERIENCE I AM THE DAUGHTER
SALVADORAN IMMIGRANT STUFF THAT
A VERY BLOODY CIVIL WAR I HAVE
FAMILY THAT WERE POLITICAL
REFUGEES ALL OVER THE WORLD.
I HAVE UNCLES AND PAIR IS I HAVE
FAMILY IN MOTHER HEAT I HAVE
FAMILY IN AUSTRALIA FAMILY IN
CANADA AND WITHOUT SUCH AN APP
LIKE WHAT'S UP I WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO COMMUNICATE WITH
MY FAMILY TWO TIMES A WEEK I SET
MY ALARM I ONE THIRTY A. M. TO
CALL MY UNCLE AND CHECK IN WITH
HIM AND IT'S MY HIGHLIGHT OF MY
WEEK.
AND THEN RECENTLY CELEB HAS
EXPANDED OUR OUR HUMANITARIAN
WORK WORKING WITH ASYLUM SEEKERS
AND NOT JUST CENTRAL AMERICAN
ASYLUM SEEKERS WORKING WITH
AFRICAN ASYLUM SEEKERS HAITIAN I
FIND SEEKERS.
AND ALSO -- INTERNALLY DISPLACED
PEOPLE IN MEXICO AND DEPORTED
PEOPLE AND BE ONE NOT SO WE'RE
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH OUR
SHELTERS AND PEOPLE DOING THE
WORK AND THE FINAL. TWO PEOPLE
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES -- IN
ADDITION TO SERVICES LIKE WHAT'S
UP AND OTHER TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS
SKYPE THAT HAVE BECOME HOUSEHOLD
NAMES THERE ARE COUNTLESS OTHER
ABSENCE SERVICES HELP AND I WANT
TO REMIND YOU THE TIME AND I
WANT TO MAKE THEIR EVERYBODY YES --
JUST CALL HIM. FOR THIS REASON I
ASK FOR THE SUPPORT FOR THE A.
B..
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHRIS ROSE ON BEHALF OF
THE NONPROFIT ALLIANCE.
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY IS PARAMOUNT TO
KEEPING THE DOORS OPEN FOR NON
PROFITS IN CALIFORNIA NON
PROFITS RELY ON ACCESS TO DATA
THE PRICE OF DATA SKYROCKETS AS
WE BELIEVE IT WILL HAPPEN IF THE
PC IS ALLOWED TO UNNECESSARILY
EXPAND ITS REACH.
THE CONSEQUENCES OF INCREASED
INCREASED PRICES HIGHER PRICES
OF DATA MEANS CHARITIES WILL NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO ABSORB THE
COST IN THOSE CHARITIES THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO STAY OPEN WILL
HAVE TO SIGNIFICANTLY CUT THEIR
PROGRAMS.
WE USE CONSUMER DATA AND THIRD
PARTY DATA PROVIDERS TO ENSURE
MARKETING MESSAGES ARE DELIVERED
TO THOSE WERE MOST LIKELY TO
BENEFIT.
WITHOUT THIS FAIR PRICE DATA
NONPROFITS CANNOT EFFECTIVELY
CONNECT WITH THOSE WHO TARGET
FOR PROGRAMMATIC COMMISSIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE THE COST PRESSURES
WOULD IMPACT THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS ABILITY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THEIR WORKERS OUR
PARTNERS AT THE U. F..
W. ARGUE CALIFORNIA FARMWORKERS
WOULD NOT RECEIVE KEY
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED ABOUT
THEIR RIGHTS UNDER STATE LAW
INCLUDING SHADE WATER BREAKS
PROTECTIVE CLOTHING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OFF THE CLOCK WORK
EMPLOYER PROVIDED TOOLS THE
RIGHT TO CONCERNED ACTIVITY.
INTO IMPROVE WAGES AND WORKING
CONDITIONS IF DATA BECOMES COST
PROHIBITIVE IF THE PC IS ALLOWED
TO EXPAND ITS REACH NONPROFITS
MAY BE THE FIRST TO SEPARATE THE
FIRST.
FULL IMPACT OF THIS CHANGE WYLER
COMPER COMMERCIAL PARTNERS ARE
FORCED TO INCREASE THEIR DATA
PRICES INCREASES THAT NONPROFITS
CANNOT ABSORB.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX PROTECTS
CHARITIES AND NON PROFITS BY
PREVENTING UNNECESSARY AND
POTENTIALLY DEVASTATING COST
PRESSURES.
NEEDLESS P. YOU SEE REACH WHILE
STILL PROTECTING CONSUMERS AND
PROMOTING PUBLIC SAFETY. FOR
THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SPORT.
YES -- MY NAME IS ERIC BROWN ON
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
TELEHEALTH NETWORK WHICH IS THE
LARGEST COLLABORATIVE.
OF SAFETY NET CLINICS AND
HOSPITALS IN THE STATE.
THAT ARE SERVING UNDERSERVED AND
RURAL PATIENT POPULATIONS.
I WANT TO START WITH JUST A VERY
BRIEF STORY AND ONLY HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
AND I DON'T WANT TO RUN A FILE
BUT I WAS I WAS IN THE TOWN OF
TEHACHAPI LAST WEEK IF YOU KNOW
WHERE TO HATCH BE IS.
IT -- IS IN THE MOUNTAINS THAT
ROOM -- THE CENTRAL VALLEY FRONT
AND A MOJAVE DESERT.
IT IS A CRITICAL ACCESS HOSPITAL
THERE -- IN THAT TOWN A YOUNG
MOM DECIDES SHE WANTS -- TO HAVE
A HOME BIRTH OF HER BABY WITH A
MIDWIFE -- THE THERE ARE
PROBLEMS -- THEY GO TO THE LOCAL
CRITICAL ACCESS HOSPITAL IN TO
HATCH A P..
WHERE THEY REALIZE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE PEDIATRIC INTENSIVE
CARE EXPERTISE THEY NEED BUT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE AN IP ENABLED
BROADBAND CONNECTION?
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
TELEHEALTH NETWORK SUPPLIED BY
AT AND T. IN THIS CASE. TO
VALLEY CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ABOUT
TWO HOURS AND SORRY ABOUT THREE
HOURS AWAY AND IN MADERA -- THE
BABY'S LIFE IS SAFE THEY'RE ABLE
TO BE MEN OF VIDEO CONFERENCE --
TO GET THE EXPERTISE THEY NEED
TO TAKE CARE OF THAT CHILD.
THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE THAT WE
SEE AND HEAR ABOUT EVERYDAY --
IN OUR TRAVELS.
IT COULD NOT BE POSSIBLE WITHOUT
THE RIGHT REGULATORY FRAMEWORK --
THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OUR ORGANIZATION WAS
ACTUALLY FORMED IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE ABOUT THE TIME THAT THE
ORIGINAL LEGISLATION.
WAS PUT IN PLACE WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO WORK CLOSELY WITH INNOVATORS
INNOVATION COMPANIES IN THE
HEALTH CARE SPACE. TO SEE HOW WE
CAN USE TECHNOLOGY TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO CARE IN RURAL AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. TWO
YEARS AGO WE MERGED WITH AN
ORGAN BASED NONPROFIT WITH A
SIMILAR MISSION CALLED OCEAN OCA
CHAYANNE IF YOU HAVEN'T HEARD OF
THEM.
THEY DO -- INNOVATION ARE AROUND
HOW DATA IS HANDLED IN
INFORMATION IS SHARED. FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS NOW ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY -- WE ARE NOW
WORKING WITH -- CHIN TO EXPAND
THE REACH OF IBM ABLE SERVICES
IN TWO WORLD AND SAFETY NET
CLINIC.
IS A TIME -- AND IT'S FOR THESE
REASONS THAT WE ALSO SUPPORT --
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL -- SUPPORT WITNESSES.
AGAIN NAME ORGANIZATION.
AND POSITION ONLY PLEASE.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS HI I'M GERRY
PASSED MORE PRESIDENT OF THE
CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA SENIORS.
AND WE RISE IN STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OF THESE THE DAVIS GOINGS
PRESIDENCY OVER THE SACRAMENTO
BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX A JOINT
COMMITTEE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S MANIC CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
GARRY MCDONALD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR LAKE HOUSE COUNTING AND
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTER IN
SUPPORT.
STEVE CARLSON CTIA THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY TRADE ASSOCIATION
HAPPEN TO BE IN SUPPORT.
COURTNEY JOHNSON WHAT TECH MEN
SPORT.%
KELLY HERE WITH THE COMPUTING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
KRISTIN NUMBERS ON BEHALF OF BAY
AREA COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
NEARLY THE DRAMA THANK YOU
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
SYLVIA GARCIA WITH RESIDENTS
GLENN FUJI NATIONAL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR -- FOR PAPA STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
LINDA IN REPRESENTING -- CA
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON RICHARD RATHER
CONCEPT AND ON BEHALF OF SOCIETY
FOR THE BLIND IN SUPPORT.
BILL DIVINE AT AND T. WE SUPPORT.
CAROLINE MCINTYRE CALIFORNIA
CABLE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
DOMINIC MARIO BEHALF OF FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS AND SUPPORT.
JOHN MOFFITT FOR COMCAST IN
SUPPORT.
PAM LIMITS ON BEHALF OF
CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS IN
SUPPORT.
GEN GET ALL OUR O. C. SACRAMENTO
PRESIDENT.
IN SUPPORT.
BUT SHEPHERD REPRESENTING THE
CAL ASIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT.
ANY MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
INCOME OF THE TABLE NOW
.
PLEASE YOU MAY BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M REGION ACOSTA
FOR TURN -- WE'RE IN OPPOSITION
IN A THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE.
THE MAIN DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE AND TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IS THAT IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE THE MAJORITY OF PHONE
LINES IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE NOT
VûI.
AND NOW THEY ARE.
ULTIMATELY ALL LAND LINE PHONE
SERVICE WILL BE PROVIDED OVER V.
O. I. P..
AND MUCH OF NOT ALL OF OUR VOICE
AND DATA IS NOW TRANSMITTED AT
LEAST IN PART OVER NETWORKS IT
THAT.
UTILIZE IP ENABLED SERVICES.
IF THIS BILL WAS ABOUT APPS WE
WOULD NOT BE IN THIS ROOM.
BUT IT ISN'T IT'S MUCH MUCH
BROADER IT HAS TO DO WITH
OVERSIGHT OVER ALL OF OUR
CRITICAL COMMUNICATION SERVICES.
V. O. I. P. UNDER THIS BILL NO
STATE AGENCY COULD TAKE ACTION
AT ADDRESSING KEY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PUBLIC SAFETY
OR CONSUMER PROTECTION ISSUES
INVOLVING AN IP ENABLE TELECOM
SERVICE.
AND LET'S THE LEGISLATURE
SPECIFICALLY PASSED A LAW
ALLOWING IT.
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA LAND LINE
PHONE SERVICE CUSTOMERS TO CALL
911- AND RECEIVE EMERGENCY
ALERTS.
AT AND T. AND OTHER VOIP
PROVIDERS SAY THAT THEY DO NOT
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THE
COMMISSION'S DISASTER RELIEF
CONSUMER PROTECTION EFFORTS
BECAUSE OF THE PROVISIONS THAT
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX SEEKS TO
EXTEND.
THE CPUC CANNOT REQUIRE VOIP
PROVIDERS OFFER LAND LINE
DISCOUNTS TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS FOR BIDDING THE CPUC
FROM OVERSEEING VOICE.
PUTS THAT PROGRAM AT RISK TO THE
DETRIMENT OF PEOPLE ON LOW
INCOMES INCLUDING THE ELDERLY
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
CARRIER OF LAST RESORT
OBLIGATIONS DO NOT APPLY TO VOIP
PROVIDERS WHICH MEANS THEY HAVE
NO OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE SERVICE
TO ALL CUSTOMERS WITHOUT
DISCRIMINATION.
THE DAY COMES WHEN V. O. I. P.
IS THE ONLY GAME IN TOWN THOSE
PROTECTIONS DISAPPEAR.
IN AN ALL I. P. WORLD CUSTOMERS
LOSE THE RIGHT TO FILE
COMPLAINTS THAT ARE ADDRESSED BY
THE CPUC OR ANY OTHER STATE
AGENCY.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE NO ONE
COULD FORESEE THE NEED FOR
ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO SHUT OFF
POWER TO PREVENT OR MITIGATE THE
THREAT OF WILDFIRES BUT THAT IS
NOW OUR REALITY.
MOST CUSTOMERS ARE USING VOICE
THOSE SERVICES THE NETWORKS
DEPEND ON COMMERCIAL POWER TO
FUNCTION AND STATE AGENCIES
CHARGED WITH ENSURING PUBLIC
SAFETY AND RELIABLE
COMMUNICATION THAT'S GOING TO
OVER TWO MINUTES BUT THE REP --
NO MATTER WHAT TECHNOLOGY IS
BEING USED WE CANNOT COMPROMISE
CONSUMER PROTECTION PUBLIC
SAFETY.
AND WE URGE YOU TO VOTE NO.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO
IN MEMBERS.
I'M TOM RUNYAN I'M PROUD TO
SERVE AS VICE PRESIDENT OF CW A
DISTRICT NINE REPRESENTING OVER
SIXTY THOUSAND WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS OUR
WORKERS ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
HAVE BEEN HEARING DIRECTLY.
FROM CONSUMERS REGARDING
PROBLEMS WITH THEIR PHONE
SERVICE OUR MEMBERS OF ALSO
WITNESSED SAFETY ISSUES WITH
PHONE LINES THAT HAVE BEEN
NEGLECTED.
DUE TO LACK OF PROPER OVERSIGHT
AND REGULATION.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR WORKERS DO NOT
SEE THESE ISSUES GETTING ANY
BETTER WITHOUT STATE
INTERVENTION SOMETHING THAT
CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS.
THE DEREGULATION OF VOICE
TELEPHONE SERVICE UNDER SB
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE HAS LED TO
SIGNIFICANT GAPS IN CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
TRADITIONAL LANDLINE TELEPHONE
COME CUSTOMERS ARE ABLE TO FILE
A COMPLAINT.
WITH THE C. P. U. C. AND THE
COMMISSION CAN TAKE ACTION.
THEY CAN BE SURE OUTAGES WILL BE
RESTORED WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS AND THEY CAN ASSUME THAT
THEIR CALLS WILL BE ANSWERED IN
A REASONABLE TIME.
UNFORTUNATELY VOIGTS USERS HAVE
NO SUCH ASSURANCES OR
PROTECTIONS.
CW A TECHNICIANS WORKING IN THE
FIELD SEE THE DISPARITY FIRST
HAND.
THEY PRIORITIZE RESTORING
TRADITIONAL PHONE SERVICE WILD
VOICE CUSTOMERS ARE LEFT WAITING.
THIS IS A FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR
SITUATION ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING
THAT MOST CUSTOMERS HAVE NO IDEA
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN SWITCHED TO
AVOID -- SERVICE IN THE FIRST
PLACE UNLIKE TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE THE MAJORITY OF HOME
PHONE SERVICE WOULD NOW BE
COVERED BY THE PROVISIONS OF AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX CW A AS LONG
SUPPORTED POLICIES THAT PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND HOLD
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SERVICE BY
EXTENDING THE PROVISIONS OF SB
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE INDEFINITELY AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX WOULD ENSURE
THAT ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE
WORKERS HAVE IDENTIFIED.
BECOME PERMANENT.
THIS WOULD GIVE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
VIRTUALLY FREE REIGN TO IGNORE
THE NEEDS OF THEIR CUSTOMERS.
NOW THAT THE MAJORITY OF HOME
PHONE CUSTOMERS IN CALIFORNIA
OUR ENVOY SWARM WITH A NEW THE
TIME LIMITS.
WITH SERVICE SWITCHING MORE AND
MORE EACH DAY.
THE DEFEAT OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
SIX WILL RESTORE CRITICAL
PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMERS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THEREFORE WE REQUEST AND URGED A
NO VOTE.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU CHAIR AND
I THOUGHT THE I GO FASTER
OBERNOLTE AYE AYE ERNESTO WITH
THE F. F. -- IF THAT'S OPPOSITE
OPPOSITION TO THIS LEGISLATION
IS VERY DIFFERENT IN NATURE WE
ARE PRIMARILY CONCERNED WITH THE
FUTURE OF BROADBAND ACCESS
COMPETITION.
A PROHIBITION ON STATE COUNTY
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE HAVING
ANY AUTHORITY OVER IP BASED
SERVICES I. E. BROADBAND.
WHEN THE FUTURE OF HIGH SPEED
ACCESS RIGHT NOW IS DEVOLVING TO
A HIGH SPEED CABLE MONOPOLY WILL
MEAN HIGHER PRICES FOR AND WHAT
LACK OF CHOICE FOR MOST OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS?
ASK YOUR FRIENDS AND FAMILY HOW
MANY CHOICES THEY HAVE AT HOME
RIGHT NOW WHEN IT COMES OF FAST
INTERNET SPEEDS AND MAJORITY
WILL TELL YOU.
ONE OR NOT.
THAT WAS NOT THE CASE IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WHEN THIS LAW
WAS ENACTED IN TWENTY TWELVE IT
DOESN'T TWELVE MOST CALIFORNIA
TWO OR THREE CHOICES. FOR SPEED
THE QUALIFIED FOR BROADBAND AND
GOOGLE WAS ENTERING THE MARKET.
YOU HAD A THE FCC REGULATE
BROADBAND FOR PROMOTING
COMPETITION ACCESS BUT TODAY YOU
HAVE NONE OF THESE.
TODAY GOOGLE STOP THE POINT
FIBER VERIZON DOESN'T TO PLAY
FILES IN EIGHTEEN TEASE FIBER
DEPLOYMENT IS A GOVERNMENT
MANDATE THAT SEAT WILL EXPIRE BY
THIS YEAR.
GOVERNMENT DATA INDICATES THAT
RULE AND LOW INCOME PEOPLE ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE FACING
MONOPOLIES ARE MOST LIKELY FACE
MONOPOLIES.
IN THE IN THE IN THE HIGH SPEED
SERVICES.
AND THAT'S NOT THE SAME STORY IN
THE INTERNATIONAL MARKETS WHERE
THEY STILL REGULATE THEIR TALK
OF SERVICES.
LASTLY I WANT TO RAISE A NAY THE
VERY SPECIFIC NARROW ISSUE BUT
THIS BILL RATE REPRESENTS.
IN REGARDS OF HOW CAN A
CATEGORICAL IT'S BEEN IS OVER BE
VOICE SERVICES.
AS I AGREE OF THE THE SENTIMENT
IF THIS WAS ABOUT APPLICATIONS
LIKE HAT'S HAPPENED SKYPE WE
WILL NOT BE HERE IF WE'RE NOT BE
INVOLVED IN OPPOSITION.
AND I WOULD KNOW BUT NONE OF THE
SUPPORTERS ARE ARE AT THE
COMPANIES TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES.
IF IT HAS WORKED OF CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS PROMOTE JUSTICE
FOR INMATES AND THEIR FAMILIES
WHEN IT COMES TO IN MAKE CARRIER
SERVICES THIS IS A DIFFERENT
INDUSTRY BEEN YOUR COMMERCIAL
INDUSTRY.
THESE ARE SIMPLY TELEPHONE
COMPANY FOR PRINTS.
THE FCC INTERVENE.
A FEW YEARS AGO BECAUSE THOSE
COMPANIES ARE CHARGING IT THE
FAMILIES OF INMATES FIFTY
DOLLARS OR MORE PERFORMANCE
PHONE CALLS.
BUT THE FEDERAL COURT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THE FCC CAN ONLY REGULATE
LONG DISTANCE CALLS THE STATE
HAS TO REGULATE LOCAL CALLS.
TODAY ON LIKE TWENTY TWELVE IS
MORRELL YOU THE TIME TO GET
THOSE SERVICES ARE VOICE
SERVICES NOT LEBANESE. FOR THESE
REASONS OTHERS I URGE YOU TO
REJECT THIS LEGISLATION.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES.
JUST A REMINDER NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATTHEW
MARKETS WITH THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE WE HAVE THE
INDEPENDENT ADVOCATE AT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND OPPOSITION.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LIZ
SORENSON WITH COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT.
NINE I STAND IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS I'M GONNA SAVE YOU SOME
TIME I'M GONNA HAVE MY FOLKS
STAND UP AS WELL THAT ARE WITH
ME TODAY HAVE BEEN HERE ALL DAY
WE'VE LOST A LOT OF FOLKS BUT WE
STAND IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF
THIS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
HI AGAIN I TRACY ROSENBERG ON
FOR MEDIA ALLIANCE WE AREN'T
STRONG OPPOSITION.
JOINT A FOOTBALL REPRESENTING A
A OUR PEACE THREE POINT THREE
MILLION MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ROGER DEAN.
PRESIDENCY WA LOCAL -- NINETY
FOUR THIRTY ONE REPRESENTING
DISTRICT ONE AND ALL THE RURAL
COMMUNITIES
AND THIS WILL HAVE A GREAT
DETRIMENT TO OUR COMMUNITIES WE
ALREADY SUFFER.
FROM DENIAL OF SERVICE FROM
THESE COMPANIES AND WE ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE. FOR THE SAKE OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS VOTE NOW.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTIES OF A MEDICINE ON
AND HUMBLE APOLOGIZE FOR THE
LATE -- SUBMISSION OF THE LETTER
BUT RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
BY CRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA ALSO LATE
TO THE OPPOSE GAME BUT HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
JEFF HARDY KIA REPRESENTING ONE
BILLION CARE A MEMBERS.
YES STRONGLY ENOUGH OPPOSITION.
COULD NOT SEE HERNANDEZ I'M HAVE
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIAN OPPOSITION.
I THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS --
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING IN HERE NO QUESTIONS -- I
WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
PRESENTING -- I HEARD VERY
CLEARLY THOUGH THERE WILL BE
SOME WORK CONTINUING ON THIS IN
IN A AND WE'VE.
GOT TO MOVE THIS BILL FOR HER TO
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION ALIVE.
I HEARD YOU VERY VERY CLEARLY ON
YOUR CONTINUING TO WORK ON
CONSUMER WORKER PROTECTIONS
WHICH I I THANK YOU FOR AN AND
DISCLOSURE TO ENSURE -- SERVICES
AND SERVICE STANDARDS AND
RESTORATION TIMES -- SO VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
CONVERSATION MOVING FORWARD AND
I REST ASSURED THAT THAT YOU'LL
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES AS
YOU MOVE FOR THE LEGISLATIVE.
PROCESS AND I HEARD YOU SAY ALSO
THAT YOU'RE GONNA TAKE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS SOMEONE BE
CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
AND THIS BILL IN ENJOYS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED ON TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
I WOULD I'M SURE THE CHAIR WILL
TAKE A LOOK AT IT -- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD -- BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
YOU KNOW A LOT OF WHAT THE
OPPOSITION SAYS I DON'T DISAGREE
WITH WE WE HAVE TO DO A BETTER
JOB OF ENSURING -- THAT RURAL
AREAS IN UNDERSERVED AREAS HAVE
SERVICE THAT THEY HAVE SERVICE
RESTORED THIS SPECIFICALLY KEEPS
THE P. YOU SEE OUT OF THE GAME
AND A PUTS THOSE REGULATIONS IN
OUR HANDS AND LET ME TELL YOU
WHY THAT'S SO IMPORTANT -- FROM
THE TIME THAT SI PC DIRECTED
STAFF TO ADD NEW SMARTPHONE
TECHNOLOGY TO THE DEATH AND
DISABLE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROGRAM IT HAS BEEN NINE YEARS
IN THE RULE MAKING PROCESS IS
STILL NOT FINALIZED IN ANOTHER
EXAMPLE WAS FOURTEEN YEARS AFTER
WIRELESS CONSUMERS BEGAN PAYING
INTO THE LIFELINE FUND.
BEFORE THEY BECAME ELIGIBLE FOR
LIFELINE IN TWO MORE YEARS
BEFORE VOIGTS CUSTOMERS ARE
CONSUMERS ARE ELIGIBLE -- FOR
THE TWO PC PROCEEDINGS MY
ASSERTION IN THIS IS THAT YOU
SEE IS NOT WORKING IT'S GREAT A
TO SUGGEST THAT WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE SOMETHING WORSE WHEN
ACTUALLY THIS IS. EIGHT AN AREA
THAT SHOULD BE LEFT TO US IT
SHOULD BE LEFT TO THE COMPLAINTS
OF OF OUR CONSTITUENTS NOW WE'RE
GOING TO WORK ON THAT THE
COMPLAIN ISSUE I A LIVE IN AN
UNDERSERVED AREA.
ABSOLUTELY I LIVE IN THE HEAD
LOVE LOVE MY NEIGHBORHOOD AND I
WILL TELL YOU IT IS HARD WE DO
NOT GET THE SAME SERVICE AS
SOMEBODY IN.
AND MAYBE.
MISS BURKHALTER VICE CITY START
UP.
IT THAT'S A THAT'S OKAY IT'S NOT
OKAY ACTUALLY I'M BUT WHAT WE
NEED TO WORK ON IT IS HOW I'M
SORRY -- WE JUST LIVE IN
DIFFERENT AREAS AND IN THE
SERVICE PROVIDED IS DIFFERENT
AND WE DO WANT TO IN NEED TO
ENSURE THAT BOTH THAT THE
SERVICE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SERVICE AND FOR COMPLAINTS AND
TO HAVE THOSE FOLLOWED UP ON IS
EQUAL AND WE ARE GOING TO WORK
WITH CW.
WAY ON ADDRESSING THAT SITUATION
I MEAN THE FOLKS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHO ARE CURRENTLY
IN OPPOSITION I TALK TO THEM
EVERY DAY OBVIOUSLY I'M NOT
DOING SOMETHING TO OPPOSE LABOR
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE.
I COME FROM AND I REPRESENT AND
THEY THEY LIVE IN MY COMMUNITY
WE WANT TO PROVIDE A FRAMEWORK
BY WHICH ACTUALLY SERVICE WILL
WILL IMPROVE THAT WE CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO SERVICE THAT WE WILL
HAVE RESTORATION TIME.
GUARANTEED IF WE LET THAT UP TO
THE P. C. WE MIGHT GET A
RESTORATION TIME FOURTEEN YEARS
FROM NOW.
ALL RIGHT SO I I WANT TO INSURE
THAT WERE ACTUALLY WRITING
THINGS INTO THIS BILL THAT THAT
STRENGTHENS THE SERVICE THAT
WE'RE GETTING NOW THAT INSURES
BY THE WEIGHT THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING NOW WITH FOR CUSTOMERS
WHEN THEY DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE'S ACCESS. TO TO BASIC
SERVICE THAT THEY'LL HAVE THAT
RIGHT IN THAT KNOWLEDGE I
ACTUALLY THINK WHAT WE'RE DOING --
IT IS GOING TO BE MUCH BETTER
FOR THE WORKERS IN THE CONSUMERS
THEN WHAT THEY WOULD GET UNDER
THE P. UC THEY THEY CAN I I
UNDERSTAND THE FEAR I UNDERSTAND.
JUST THIS IDEA OF REGULATION BUT
WE AS LEGISLATORS I THINK I'M
FAR BETTER POSITION TO
IMMEDIATELY ACT ON THESE THINGS
THEN LEAVING IT UP TO THE PC SO
THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING YOU DO.
TODAY A WE'RE GONNA SEE OTHER
BILLS THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION
ON ON VOIGTS SERVICES IN
DISASTER AREAS AND AND THINGS
COMING THROUGH AND I THINK WE
ARE ABLE TO REGULATE THIS IT'S
NOT -- IT'S NOT THE DAYS OF OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WHEN THERE
WAS A MONOPOLY THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF SERVICES AVAILABLE AND
WE DO BY THE WAY WE HAVE SEEN
INTERNET.
ACCESS TO INTERNET PRICES GO WAY
DOWN UNDER UNDER THIS TYPE OF OF
NOT REGULATION BY THE PC AND I
HOPE TO CONTINUE WITH THAT.
WE BROUGHT UP THE ISSUE OF BEING
ABLE TO ACCESS FREE CALLS
INTERNATIONALLY BECAUSE THAT'S A
HUGE -- BENEFIT THAT WE'VE SEEN
THANKS TO THE FACT THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THE P. C. MEDELLIN AND
ISSUES LIKE THAT I'M SORRY I
HATE. TO TO BE SO DOWN ON THE P.
YOU SEE KIND OF BUT IT JUST IT
HASN'T BEEN EFFECTIVE AND I KNOW
I KNOW THAT MY FRIENDS IN LABOR.
UNDERSTAND THAT AND SO I HOPE
THAT THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS WE
CAN CONTINUE TO WORK TO MAKE
SURE CONSUMERS ARE BETTER OFF
WORKERS ARE BETTER OFF BUT THAT
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS AND
COMPETITION IN A WAY THAT SERVES
OUR COMMUNITY THE BASS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY THANK
YOU. TO HAVE A FIRST.
AND A SECOND.
I I BELIEVE WE DID I APOLOGIZE
ABOUT THAT MA'AM SIX EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DEPOSITS AMENDED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I BURN A HOLE THAT BUT
A WHOLE THAT I BONTA.
BONTA AYE BRO [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON I HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I LOVE
[inaudible]
PATTERSON.
ALISON I HOPE SILVA.
BOOKS OVER ON AYE RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ SIGH.
PRO.
ROLL ON MY THAT CAN DOES YOUR
MEASURES OUT.
THE GOOD NEWS IS ONE SECOND CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
YEAH
.
POLITICAL -- MADAM SECRETARY
RELIVE THE CALL AND SO ON ON
ITEM NUMBER TWO AND A HALF OVER
YOU FOR THE BILLS.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB.
FIVE TWO THREE LIFT IN THE CALL.
BONTA BONTA I PRO [inaudible]
BONO [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
LOW.
PATTERSON NO PATTERSON NO.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB -- FIVE TWO
THREE WHEN LIFT IN THE CALL
HOLDEN [inaudible]
HOLDEN I
EIGHT TWO MEASURES OUT.
ALL OF THE EYES WITH DISPENSED
WITH WILL NOW BEGIN OUT ON I'M
NUMBER ONE AB ONE ONE SIX EIGHT
SANTIAGO.
I SANTIAGO I WROTE [inaudible]
BRO I HOLDEN [inaudible]
HOLDEN I LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
ON ONE I'M NUMBER ONE A. B.
[inaudible]
PATTERSON I CONTROL RESULT YOU
WERE SORT OF CONSENT CALENDAR.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE BRO [inaudible]
BRO I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I LOW
.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB [inaudible]
ONE THREE SIX SIX HOLDEN
[inaudible]
HOLDEN I LOW.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB.
ONE SIX NINE NINE BRO.
BRO I HOLDEN [inaudible]
HOLDEN I LOW.
LISTEN.
PATTERSON AYE. TWENTY MISTER
LARA
. FOR PURPOSES OF ADD ON
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB ONE ONE SIX
EIGHT LOW.
LOW ON MY ITEM NUMBER TWO AB.
EIGHT FIVE TWO THREE LOW.
LOW ON MY CONSENT CALENDAR.
HELLO [inaudible]
LOW I ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB ONE
THREE SIX SIX LOW.
LOW ON MY I'M NUMBER SIX AB ONE
SIX NINE NINE LOW.
LOW ON MY THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
BACK THE COMMITTEE ON
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE WE
ARE ADJOURNED